- Hey, what's up everybody?
Welcome to Stupid
Questions: Roast Edition.
(imitating sizzling)
(laughing)
I'm here with Nikki Glaser,
Brian Moses, Coach Tea,
and Dom Irrera.
- A lot of people
don't know this.
We went to grade school, high
school, and college together.
- True
- And to see you again,
it breaks my heart,
I love you so much.
- Dom, I appreciate
that, I really do.
(rock music)
Here we're gonna play
this little game.
It's a fill-in-the-blank game.
So Bruce Willis is a lousy what?
- French kisser, and
I'll tell you why.
He does the thing with his
tongue, the twirling thing.
It just gets all my, I see
where you stop it and relax
and just (beep) rub the tongue.
- I would love to
roast Bruce Willis.
- Would you?
- Yeah.
- You said you
don't like roasting.
- No, I know, but I'm
a fan of Bruce Willis,
so I would like to...
- What's your favorite
Bruce Willis movie?
- Look Who's Talking.
- Really?
- 100 percent.
- If I was roasting
Bruce Willis,
it's like those eyes
are crystal blue.
I would just get kinda
getting lost in your eyes now.
- Oh, thank you.
- No problem.
- I don't think he
makes eye contact.
- Oh yeah, I've heard that.
- I've heard that
on set you can't.
So I think that's why.
It's not that he's rude or
he thinks he's above it,
he doesn't want people
falling in love with him.
Because then it can distract
from the work he needs to do.
- Just goes full Stevie Wonder.
What do you think his
tomb stone would say?
- "Why are you staring
at me like that?"
- Maybe it'd say "Look
who's not talking now".
You know, because of the
movie Look Who's Talking.
All right.
(rock music)
What would you say is your
most roastable attribute?
- If I were roasting me,
I'd go after the fact
that I don't have an ass.
(laughing)
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- You would just, yeah
that you're just assless.
- Yeah that I just
have a long back,
I think that that's a good one.
- I don't need an ass,
to be honest with you.
- Thank you for saying that.
- Absolutely, and I mean that.
- I lost it in the war.
- The thing about
me, I'm so adorable.
- You really are.
- You know, with this whole
puffy-faced closed-eyes look
that I'm going for.
I don't know what they
could possibly say about me.
(rock music)
- Brian Moses, who is the
referee of Roast Battle.
Do you have pre-battle,
pre-Roast Battle pump-up music?
- I'm a jazz guy.
- Interesting.
- Yeah a lot of Coltrane.
Unity's smooth because
it's so vicious.
- I'm always listening to
Taylor Swift because she is...
I like to think of myself as
the Taylor Swift of comedy.
A lot of people
have called me that
because I've asked them to.
- I'm here with
Coach Tea the DJ.
Here's a stupid question.
- [Coach Tea] All right.
- What do you think, what's
the dumbest song that you feel
you've had to play
during a roast battle?
- I have an interesting role
because whenever the comedians
come out to battle, I'm
always trying to make fun.
- Yeah.
- So one time there was a
guy and he had a short arm.
And so I played a song
that just kept repeating
"Put that hands up in the air".
And everyone's laughing
because he literally can't
because he's got a
little miniature arm.
(rock music)
- Have you ever
roasted someone so hard
that you really felt
guilty afterwards?
- No, no.
- You just, doesn't matter?
- It usually happens to me.
And they were like
"Oh I feel guilty
because I was so mean to you."
- We roasted Ann
Coulter last time.
- Oh yes.
- And I went really hard
on her and it felt great.
I didn't have any
regrets about it.
So I never wanna say anything
that's gonna make someone
feel terrible about who they are
unless they're a terrible
person like Ann Coulter.
And then it's like
you need to know.
I didn't have to
hold back at all.
- Have you ever
roasted someone so hard
that you felt guilty afterwards?
- You know who Jack Palance is?
- Jack, oh yeah of
course, City Slickers.
- He got mad at people.
I heard Chevy Chase did too.
- Why?
- But you can't, he goes.
Somebody would say something,
and he'd go "(beep) you".
I don't think he got the
theme of this whole thing.
It's a joke.
- Jack Palance, he's
dead now, right?
- He's either dead or
having a tremendous lull
in his career.
- Here's something, because
I don't like to roast really,
because I don't like
to be mean, right?
And you're a really nice
guy, I can tell that.
But you're a part of
this Roast Battle show
where people are
slamming people.
So how do you get into your
place where you can just be mean
just for a little bit?
- I love it because I don't
consider it to be mean.
- Okay.
- Because I don't think
anybody should ever have
power over you, period.
So when something
actually agitates you,
that's a moment in
your life, and be like
"Why am I so
uncomfortable with that?"
- That was some Roast
Battle Gandhi shit.
- (laughing) Yeah.
(rock music)